là
bienvenue dans le golden shoe numéro
bonsoir énergie dans ce golden shoe un
véritable show de music-hall mesdames et
messieurs ce soir et on va pas sous de
votre gueule parce que dès l'intro
mesdames et messieurs j'ai préparé moi
même tout seul une super intro pour
cette émission d'accord ok tout seul
dans ton coin donc on s'envoie plus de
mails plus de pièces attachées les
publications adrien nom pour cette intro
mesdames et messieurs j'ai préparé ma
danse d'intro ok ok ok bah fait le fait
le tout seul
ok je te regarde
geof merci vous rendez compte que vous
vendez quand vous êtes en train
d'applaudir un mec qui a préparé un
début de spectacle de cm2 c'est nul
c'est très mauvais heureusement que j'ai
prévu une intro tout seul dans mon coin
aussi si une intro au yoyo et des trois
mois je vais relever la barre plus haute
que cette phrase elle existe pas et
maintenant le robin des bois
des vies je crois que cette histoire
vient de m'apprendre quelque chose ah
ouais je crois que la morale de cette
histoire
ouais c'est qu'en unissant nos forces on
devient bien meilleure pour une intro
mais toi dans mon dos je ne comprends
pas ce que tu veux on va faire comme au
liban en 1968 souviens toi on avait été
exceptionnel ce soir là je me souviens
attention fulgurant coin collectionna
tient à prendre sa quote part en
rémission attention chemise car voilà
une auréole de sketches papa les fils on
peut gagner c'est la première fois qu'il
vient la région c'est peut-être un jeu
et on joue pas avec la langue française
tu joues je veux passer mon tour et je
vais changer mais net à moi donc je mets
trois lettres
je rajoute j'ai ramadi ça fait germany
22 points mots qu'on double à toi
linoléum à toi
assurer le bon jour attends je te
rappelle howie lundi que moi au lieu
notre dame de paris notre dame de paris
c'est par là je crois ok faites pas
votre français et dites moi où l'île
notre dame de paris aucun orgueil
wargame comprends pas with notre-dame de
paris
vous les français vous dites toujours la
mauvaise direction soit vous connaissez
pas votre pays soit vous êtes un raciste
de mer dont je sais pas vous êtes jaloux
de notre puissance mondiale ou quoi non
c'est par là c'est par là ok ça fait
deux jours que je suis apparu le capital
du neuf ok elle peut la pisse
ok c'est dégueulasse par terre lotoise
knicks le cas d'un troquet au french
people à des glaces alors faites un
effort
d'accord d'accord d'accord
d'accord
date my boys boys boys boys dans leur
carte vais je vais voir mon nez alors
nous en plus de pas connaître occupez
vous êtes super je n'ai jamais en france
c'est vraiment puis de la mer dans la
france c'est la chiasse de l'europe ok
donc nous on est là je m'en fous de
savoir où en est notre dame je m'en fous
je veux faire ma photo et je vais me
casser ok ok notre dame de paris
c'est là
kennedy
ouais notamment chérif et de découvrir
quelqu'un et j'ai résolu beaucoup d'
enquête avec elle au 10è s'est dit on va
dans mon passage secret on va récupérer
des chevaux et on attaque les allemands
y est ça y est ouais mais c'est mon
livre ça commence à bath aimé le livre
que j'ai écrit
ouais ouais ok tu te sers de mon lit
pour faire le mécanisme d'ouverture de
ta cachette secrète
oui honte arracher des pages en fait oui
mais oui mais je les ai gardés super je
les ai regardés vous dans une pochette
plastique elle est où la pochette
plastique dans ma vie à take away elle
est où la pochette plastique dans ta
bibliothèque aller où tu as rangé où
elle est ou non non même pas non pas
dans cette bibliothèque dans ma
bibliothèque de ma maison à biarritz
n'importe quoi ben quoi n'importe quoi
si j'ai une maison à biarritz pourquoi
j'en parle mais en vérité je fais du
surf j'adore le surf tu peux demander à
bernardo banon regardent ils nous
écoutent pas en tout cas je trouve ça
vraiment pas sympa je trouve ça se fait
trop parce que tu as fait en plus je me
rappelle très bien c'est un livre que je
t'avais dédicacé j'avais fait un peu un
personnalisé pour toi un truc qui
touchent vraiment sûr sur les chevaux ok
ok donc on se dit tous ont dit qu on se
dit tout ok donc quand je ne fais pas ça
choquerait je me suis dit il faut que je
prenne un livre qui actionne le
mécanisme que personne ne lit hockey et
le livre que personne ne lit pas c'est
ton livre je suis désolé c'est en duo et
en plus tu es poèmes il rime pas
ok bah normal donc vu que c'est de la
prose donc certain que ça va pas bon
voila tout cas très sympa super sympa
super ambiance
ok on dit qu'on oublie et on prend un de
passages secrets d'accord je perds un
accord quoi quoi
rends-toi l'ex luthor oh oui je savais
que j'allais venir me chercher et j'ai
tout prévu superman mais je tiens
retrouvé malgré le fait que tu caches
dans un immeuble en plomb ça aussi gelé
prévu le salut me bloquait qui ne
pouvait pas voir au travers était
forcément ma cachette
tu avais prévu du 2 juin avait prévu de
tuer avait prévu de mettre tu ne pouvais
pas arrête de faire le perroquet fit
envoyer des mails répondu à ça aussi je
l'avais prévu je savais qu'on allait
passer par ce chemin et jeté minutes à
peine tard tu as un cerveau malade l'ex
je vais t'emmener en taule je m'échappe
ray comme d'habitude alors je te
rattrape après tu sais le mieux ce
serait que tu restes avec moi tu restes
tout le temps avec moi parce que je fais
rien des bêtises quand t'es pas là à
l'écriture m'a emmène moi danser
forteresse de solitude on vivra tous les
deux je te ferai à manger de ménage je
comprends pas tu vois à travers les murs
ça veut dire qu'ils voient à travers mes
vêtements tu aimes bien ce que tu vois
tu aimes bien je vis en acier sais pas
si c'est comme toi tu sais moi je vois
pas à travers les murs mais tout cas je
peux voir que à travers tes vêtements
que tu es bien pâtit est-ce que je peux
t'appeler calais tu m as kryptonite
bassal lex luthor qui est moi qui a pu
faire ça superman je sais pas du tout
c'est étrange on dirait qu'il a explosé
de l'intérieur ouais c'est bizarre c'est
comme si un marteau piqueur l'avait
vieux os
est ce que c'est ça qu'est ce que c'est
que ça c'est quoi cette matière verte et
gluant je sais pas c'est pas je vais y
aller moi c'est dingue on dirait je suis
seul
bon merci alors est ce que vous pourriez
l'imprimé deux attestations soit oui
bien sûr je vous en prie aime ça tout de
suite a alors voilà par contre j'ai plus
d'encre tube désolé c'est pas grave
comme on parce que petite fille
il existe trois héros parce que petite
fille le monde est tellement bout ils
sont sûrs bleus jo de londres où ils
sont rouges et jaunes jaune et bleu
ils viennent pour les jours heureux ils
ont 24
et pourtant deux sans trois tout le
monde leur nom bouge ton corps est en
joie car ils viennent te mets
être une carte ou
vas-y ouvre le clapet il arrive là je
fais thierry vas-y d'accord
est-ce que ça se passe bien ce soir pour
vous
je n'entends
non je n'entends rien j'ai beaucoup de
cérumen et je n'entends rien ok ce soir
mesdames et messieurs le golden shoe se
la joue music hall et vous en met plein
la vue et tout de suite un spectacle
extraordinaire rien que pour vous alors
je vais avoir besoin de l'aide de
quelqu'un dans le public pour m'aider à
réaliser ce numéro christian est ce que
tu peux allumé la salle ouais tout le
monde sait bien habillé alors il y
aurait-il bombe aider dans ce numéro
exceptionnel
y aurait-il pour m'aider un tigre dans
la salle oui moi à il y un tigre ce soir
mes amis et messieurs sfar bonsoir on
peut applaudir le tigre qui veulent
rejoindre sur scène oui vous pouvez me
rejoindre sur scène
ah non ça me faire passer pour un con ça
vous allez allez vous allez venir sur
scène pour jouer un sketch avec moi non
non je fais pas les andouilles merci
waouh je crois que cette histoire n'a
appris quelque chose et je crois que la
morale de cette histoire c'est qu'il
faut toujours avoir un tigre sur soi
j'ai dit que je mentais pas sur scène
oui bon ça va ta gueule c'est bon
mesdames et messieurs prenez des
mitraillettes carmassi une rafale de
sketches ringarde j'ai une corde
invisible regardez regardez j'ai aussi
un herpès génital invisible garde bien
merci
http de points ça se lâche bonjour
d'hier vu dans fast food le journaux des
réseaux social aujourd'hui au sommaire
de cette édition un dossier spécial
consacré aux filtres am stram gram du
moment et puis nous recevrons magic
virgin mais tout de suite on commence
avec le truite de la semaine il est
signé terry bouboule qui nous dit mdr
lol ma soeur est tombé dans les
escaliers suivi quelques minutes plus
tard du truite la [__] elle a cassé ma
psp sans transition c'est un magicien à
ce book que vous vous souvenez très
certainement de son pittoresque que
numéro du lapin qui sort du chapeau en
plusieurs images donc nous recevons
magic virgile virgile bonjour bonjour je
suis très content d'être là et bien ça
fait moins une personne heureuse virgile
de votre nouveau tour qu'est ce que
c'est je fais disparaître des pages
internet alors par exemple prend une
page au hasard par exemple cette page le
bon droit
voilà vingt ans théo break alors là
d'accord c'est tout oui cette page n'est
plus disponible
si manger autre chose
regardez cette photo alors cherchez je
ne comprends pas où sont les pièces
d'échecs ne va pas jouer en mode sans
échec à l'ara quel talent merci virgile
culture maintenant une exposition qui se
tient sur amstramgram flirte avec les
filtres de l'artiste peintre ibrahim
celui ci qui sans mauvais jeu de mots
s'infiltre dans les filtres au fil des
fils tu es qui ont regardé finir le
filtre bien connu dit sirha le x pro le
rail mais aussi le kitty kitty
le ninja art le sanex et la dernière
création d'ibrahim que voici
alors pour parler de ce dernier fils
très bien nous avons la chance de
recevoir l'artiste
ibrahim alors ibrahim d'où vous est
venue l'idée de ce nouveau filtre
d'accord on fait comment s'appelle ce
nouveau filtre la mer noire à travers
votre atelier où est-ce qu'on peut le
trouver
la mer noire très bien merci beaucoup
ibrahim est bien chez la femme de ce
fast food le journaux des réseaux social
demain vous retrouver guillaume pétait à
13h pour le journal s'il retrouve sur
login et son mot de passe
et d'ici là n'oubliez pas de ff asplund
[__] je n'ai dit la mer noire donc
cette agression ait lieu hier soir c'est
ça est-ce que vous avez vu est très
serré c'est peut-être nous aider on va
faire un portrait robot essayé dans la
base de données aux la trappe accord
j'ouvre le logiciel et je vous pose
quelques questions
on est parti alors est ce que votre
agresseur est un homme dans ces des
questions de base en donc
oui oui est ce que votre agresseur
aurait plus de 30 ans oui oui est ce que
votre agresseur serait-il de votre
famille à cause de ma famille dans ce
cas je serai qui sait ouais bah vous dit
non alors non non non non ce n'est pas
non est-ce que votre agresseur aurait
déjà enregistré un disque un discours et
que je sache c'est quoi ces questions au
sérieux si on se qualifie le protocole
on répond à vos questions vous savez pas
où dit non alors est ce que votre
agresseur serait-il décédé je veux
marquer non et c'est que votre agresseur
aurait t'il d origine asiatique
oui ah oui oui attendez est ce que votre
agresseur serait-il un humoriste mais
oui oui oui
est ce que votre état soeur aurait-il
une chronique tous ici ça mais oui la
chronique télé j'ai trouvé ce jean luc
lemoine
vous l'avez trouvé cliquant plus
seulement
je sais pas de combat cusin et clients
ne parlera pas je ne sais pas qui est ce
délateur qui est akinator mais au vu de
son accoutrement un petit gilet un
turban sur la tête je ne pense pas qu'il
ait ses papiers nationalité française
merci à tous ouais ouais ouais c'est un
mur porteur mais je peux vous le pt j'ai
commencé vraiment goûté ça un maçon vous
le ferez à 2005
moi je suis honnête je vous fais à 500
autres mais par exemple je pue de la
gueule
on m'a bannis mais je reviendrai à paris
petite cosette je te suivrai
quand
pour
bibeau on a vécu bien des aventures
sache que
cent vingt ans je t'aurais dit pauvre un
peu à côté de travailler dans la
restauration avant de prendre mon
service je vais me rendre un petit
service de verton petit moineau match et
aura pour son argent
tu ne sauvera pas vous être tout d'abord
la lame de mon épée on va jeter de la
creuse corrèze
la maman
et les misérables s'il a reculé
petite cause et ils t'ont fait du mal
non c'est bon je me débrouille comment
ça ils t'ont fait du mal une petite
cosette ans ils font toucher la csn
présentement on voit tu as des années
mon poids que les émissions de merde
pensez vous qu'à soir
en face au cab roche est une roche
jardin des galoches oui c'est toi et oui
au tombeau notre région pour défendre le
film les misérables recherche de jeunes
garçons talentueux pour les rôles de
cosette et gavroche
merci d'envoyer vos candidatures à
contacter universal at caramel pour ben
e
bonsoir et bienvenue pour un combat doit
qui s'annonce exceptionnel ce soir 9 ans
jean-paul absolument steve nos deux
combattants non dans la fange
sevré de côté hier stéphane qui a quand
même été trois fois champion du monde de
combat de pouce il a gagné ses trois
derniers matches ce bâtiment les lui
donner des envies dix ans
l'autre michel redoutable car il a été
six fois vainqueur du titre
international de chifoumi avec une
finale mémorable de l'année dernière il
a gagné par pierre au quotidien as mais
ce soir c'est le grand soir
car ils vont s'affronter en free fight
tous les coups sont permis
et c'est parti le match commence
première vue mais un coup de doigt
ça commence fort oui michel aurait dû
protéger son doigt avec son doigt mais
se redresse très bon jeu de cuticules
colombie
il doit s'en mordre les lui même il
s'éloigne il va chercher mais qu'est ce
qu'il fait oh c'est une feuille de
papier fait mal à garder
on dirait que stéphane a un flash back
bébel je sais que tu es le meilleur tu
veux gagner ce combat
quand tu seras sur le ring je croiserai
les moi même ce flashback nous a redonné
du courage il se redresse
mais même face
baird match de la part de cette ligne
roset de dong thap et sous le seuil des
tractations ont été gâtés de la seule
j'ai pas nous devons arrêter deux pas
des arènes petit pavé c'était le
grenelle shawn yonhap
merci merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission
merci beaucoup je crois que cette
histoire m'a appris un truc
quelle histoire et je crois que la
morale de cette histoire des vies c'est
qu'un bourreau va venir sur scène on
peut applaudir le petit patxi et sebourg
mesdames et messieurs ce bourg on vient
ici pour te couper la [__] de vie
pourquoi quelle occasion ok on en quoi
ben justement c'est dans ce genre de
circonstances qu'on emploie cet adage
bien connu qui est que tout bug dans ça
n'a aucun sens qui viennent te couper la
[__] ce soir mais ça a été déjà payé par
la prod
désolé si ceux payés par la prod alors
on se donne rendez-vous bientôt après
les la campagne vacances à tous et est
le colonel chanteuse
et je m'étire coupet
je n'oublie rebonds
m
que